the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi welcome to calculus part 2 where our
theme for the entire course will
essentially be functions of several
variables but a more underlying theme a
theme which will not only prima eight
this course but virtually every course
in the mathematics curriculum and
perhaps other curricular as well is the
idea of what we mean by a mathematical
structure and if this sounds a little
bit ominous and frightening the idea of
a mathematical structure can be compared
very nicely in terms of a game and for
this reason I have chosen to entitle our
first lesson the game of mathematics the
game of mathematics and let's emphasize
the word game here we do not mean game
in a trivial sense where in elementary
school the first row races the second
row to see who finishes the addition
problem first the idea that we want to
talk about is what is a game and I
remember an old riddle when I was in
about the fourth or fifth grade when
somebody said to me what is it that
looks like a box smells like cheese and
flies and the answer was a flying cheese
box and the interesting point is that
this is how in the scientific world we
often make up definitions namely to
define a game we try to think of every
single ingredient that is common to
every game and then we roll all of these
ingredients into one long definition and
that becomes our final definition and
with that in mind let me take the
following tack and again let me point
out that I am going through this rather
hurriedly because the main aim of the
lesson is to give an overview with the
idea that the supplementary notes and
the exercises that the in the unit will
give you the computational drill that
you need but for a first approximation
let us say that in any game you must
have definitions so to know what
terminology you have then you must have
rules of
and noticed that the rules of the game
our relationships between the terms or
was a trivial example in playing cards
there are many different card games that
can be played with the same deck of
cards what makes the game difference is
different different are not the
definitions involved but the rules of
the game and finally there are
objectives
well obviously the objective of any game
is to win what we really mean by an
objective is the art of carrying out a
winning situation by successfully
employing the definitions and the rules
alright and the way we do that is
usually called strategy strategy is the
art of using the definitions and rules
to carry out the objective in an
inescapable manner and the reason I like
this particular little setup is it gives
me a way to show you in juxtaposition
the role of rote versus reason logic
versus memory in any mathematical
situation or real-life situation namely
the strategy part of a game is logic and
things like the definitions and the
rules are things that we memorize ok now
the thing that we're going to do in our
particular course is always come back to
this particular structure in other words
our definition of a game is any system
which consists of definitions rules and
objectives where the objective is
carried out as an inescapable
consequence of the definitions and the
rules by means of strategy and by the
way don't take this lightly
this is a very serious topic later in
the course the computation will become
sufficiently difficult that we may lose
sight of the forest because of the trees
right now what I want to do is emphasize
this to you in terms of topics that
you're already familiar with so as you
can see what the overall structure of
mathematics is so she will not be
preoccupied with this when we're
learning more computational things let
me just take a look at well a relatively
trivia
example I call this a new look at
counting we all know how to count we
start with a number called one and we
have various definitions 1 plus 1 is 2 2
plus 1 is 3 3 plus 1 is 4 4 plus 1 is 5
5 plus 1 is 6 6 plus 1 is 7 etc ok so
far so good now we ask the question how
much is 4 plus 3 now obviously we all
know that 4 plus 3 is 7 we're not saying
what are we looking at this problem for
what we're trying to show now is a very
important aspect of the game of
mathematics you see notice there in our
list of definitions no place do we have
the sum 4 plus 3 define what we are
interested in now is not so much the
truthful statement that 4 plus 3 is 7
but whether the result 4 plus 3 equals 7
follows inescapably from the definitions
that we've listed now you see the point
is our we've listed at definitions we
haven't told any particular rules of the
game yet well let's make up some rules
as we go along and as I say we'll
discuss these in more details in our
notes and in the exercises we
essentially do something like this we
write down 4 plus 3 okay then we say ok
we do know how to add by ones that's
what our definition says so we rewrite 3
as 2 plus 1 in other words we substitute
2 plus 1 which is equal to 3 by
definition then we say ok 2 plus 1 is
the same as 1 plus 2 now by the way
notice the tacit assumption that we're
making we're assuming that the order in
which you add two numbers makes no
difference obviously this is not a rule
in every game of life in most things in
life order does make a difference
consider for example the statements
first I am dressed and then I take a
shower or first I shower and then I
undress without meaning to pass judgment
as to which is proper at least notice
there is a difference between the two
what we're saying is that somehow or
other in the game of arithmetic we
assume the addition has the property
the order in which you add makes no
difference so we say okay let's accept
that as a rule of the game if we accept
that as a rule of the game 2 + 1 can
then be substituted for by 1 + 2 we make
the additional assumption that when you
add three numbers the answer does not
depend on voice inflection in other
words that 4 + 1 + 2 is equal to 4 + 1 +
2 + the strategy behind doing that is
that we know that another name for 4
plus 1 is 5 in other words we now arrive
at the fact that 4 plus 3 is equal to 5
plus 2 we now rewrite 2 as 1 plus 1 and
we now have that 5 + 2 is the same as 5
plus 1 plus 1 we now again use the fact
that voice inflection makes no
difference and we rewrite this as 5 + 1
+ 1 5 + 1 we know by definition is 6 + 6
+ 1 we know by definition is 7 in other
words subject to the rules that we've
talked about implicitly here but have
not stated in our game format explicitly
what we have shown is that if we accept
certain rules it follows from our
definitions that 4 plus 3 equals 7 is an
inescapable conclusion
notice that the inescapability of the
conclusion hinges on the fact that we've
accepted certain rules if we change the
rules we can change the conclusions in
other words this thing called drawing
inescapable conclusions is something
called validity and validity involves
the art of drawing inescapable
conclusions using given rules and given
definitions we will talk about that in
more detail but for now notice the
difference here before we did this we
knew as a conjecture a past experience
thing that 4 plus 3 equals 7 is a true
statement what we now know is in terms
of certain rules of the game
coupled with the definitions that we've
accepted 4 plus 3 equals 7
an inescapable conclusion henceforth to
be called a theorem in our game let's
see if we can't get away from this
rather simple example and again let me
emphasize that as simple as this example
is throughout our course we will be
using the same technique only at a more
sophisticated level of computational
skill but let's take a look here and see
what we're really saying what
mathematical structure really involves
is a logic machine type of thing we have
a logic machine a machine that being fed
any kinds of definitions rules
assumptions etc grinds these things
through and has as the out as its output
inescapable conclusions ok in other
words you feed in definitions rules etc
which by the way don't really have to be
true in the real life sense of being
true I mean for example in the baseball
game to say the rule is three strikes as
and out there is certainly no basic
truth that said that that had to be the
case what is true is that in the world
of science the scientist is the
interpreter of neisha what happens in
real life happens where the scientist
predicts it or not what he tries to do
is to make up definitions and rules
which are compatible with his experience
things which he calls truth he feeds us
through his logic machine draws
inescapable conclusions and if the
conclusions follow inescapably
from the definitions and the rules
recall the result in argument valid in
other words truth is a value judgment
that we make about a particular
statement validity is a more objective
thing that we attribute to an argument
in other words a statement is either
true or false an argument is either
valid or invalid meaning that we only
judge where the conclusion of the
argument follows inescapably from the
given assumptions independently of where
those assumptions happen to be true or
not by the way as an aside one of the
reasons the
the scientist prefers to dodge issues
such as what is truth and leaves that to
the philosopher is the truth in many
cases is a relative thing it's based on
the available knowledge it's also based
on the situation that we want to handle
in other words what is truth and my
claim is that the answer depends on the
situation but let me give you again a
trivial arithmetic situation
there's 1/2 plus 1/3 equals 5/6 or does
1/2 plus 1/3 equal 2/5 and again the
answer is it depends on what real-life
problem you're dealing with for example
if a person is working for you by the
hour and he works for you for a half
hour one day and 1/3 of an hour the next
day the total time he's worked is 5/6 of
an hour why because this agrees with our
real-life experience that 30 minutes
plus 20 minutes is 50 minutes on the
other hand if a baseball player goes 1
for 2 in the first game of a
doubleheader and 1 for 3 in the second
game of the doubleheader he has batted 2
hits in five times at bat in fact if you
could convince the public that he had
five hits and six times at bat you could
become a director of any economy program
in the nation I guess the point however
is this in most arithmetic questions
that we deal with we are used to the
physical interpretation in which 1/2
plus 1/3 equals 5/6 reflects the
real-life situation whereas this example
here may seem trivial namely how often
are you going to be involved with
batting averages unless you're doing 6th
grade arithmetic the point remains
ironically or whatever you want to call
it that this little batting average
problem is not trivial in the world of
engineering we know this example as the
weighted average problem in other words
you will notice that 2 over 5 as a
fraction is more nearly equal to 1/3
then it is equal to 1/2 and the reason
for that is that the player batted at
the lower
average one over three one hit and three
times at bat four more times at bat in
other words the three has a heavier
weighting factor than the two and every
time that you use a weighted average in
a scientific engineering oriented
investigation this is the truth not this
in other words it is neither true nor
false that 1/2 plus 1/3 equals 2/5 or
that 1/2 plus 1/3 equals 5/6 which is
true depends on the particular physical
situation you see a rather interesting
point here that we sometimes allow truth
to be based on what particular problem
we're trying to solve another way that
we manipulate truth is that we sometimes
have a rule that we like to be true in
fact I guess this is probably what
happens with most political theories
that one starts with the objectives
knows what it is that he wants to be
true and then invents the definitions
and the rules to conform with this in
much the same way as around the 4th
grade again we learn such adages as look
before you leap and two minutes later
you learn he who hesitates is lost and
suddenly you come to the conclusion that
you can make your assumptions validity
any conclusion you want just by choosing
your assumptions appropriately now if
that sounds degrading let me show you
how it's used effectively in mathematics
in other words let me just say that
predetermined rules may control truth
let me give you an example going back to
exponents why does B to the 0 equal 1
the answer is very simple that when we
used positive exponents positive whole
number exponents we talked about that
many factors of B and one of the
interesting rules that we saw that was
obeyed by whole number exponents was
that if you multiply B to the M power by
B to the nth power you got as an answer
B to the M + n power okay B to the M + n
now the interesting thing is
after a while you never even paid
attention to why this rule worked what
you didn't know was that this was a
pretty darn convenient rule to use
computationally this rule simplified
many particular combination computations
that you were doing in particular then
as soon as n is zero you would still
like to be able to use this rule in
other words we want this nice rule to
apply even when N equals zero now let's
look at this from a computational point
of view if we want this rule to apply
when N equals zero let's simply rewrite
this exactly as it appears here with n
equal to zero
alright we then have what we have B
we'll just repeat everything here B to
the M times B now we're replacing n by
zero so that's B to the zero and that
must equal B to the M plus n that's M
plus zero but the interesting point is
that we know how to add numbers and for
numbers M plus zero is M in other words
this is still B to the M now we look at
this and what we're saying is if we want
the rule B to the M times B to the n to
equal B to the M plus n to be true even
when n is zero
this says that B to the zero must be
that number such that when we multiply
it by B to the M we get B to the M now
what number has the property that when
you multiply it by B to the M you get B
to the M and if you're real quick you
say 1 and if your algebra oriented you
say B to the zero is therefore equal B
to the M divided by B to the M and again
you say 1 except of course that B must
be unequal to 0 because hopefully by
this time we understand why we must
never divide by 0
in other words what we now have is the
old high-school rule that B to the zero
equals one provided
B is unequal to zero but here's the
important point if I have never defined
B to the zero and somebody says to me
make up a definition for B is a zero and
I say ok B to the zero is going to be 36
I have every right in the world to make
up that definition what I don't have a
right to do is when I'm ever using an
expression like B to the zero is to
assume that I have the right to use this
particular recipe in other words if I
want to be able to use the nice recipe
even when n is zero I have no choice but
to define B to the zero to equal 1
therefore we make up that definition
because we want that recipe to apply and
that's exactly what we're going to be
doing through most of this course we are
going to look at certain real-life
situations we are going to look at
certain recipes that we want to apply
and we are going to make up definitions
this way and then see how our
inescapable conclusions follow from
these definitions more about that will
be said in the remainder of this unit
and our next lecture we'll pick up the
game of mathematics in a different
context but until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate